hey guys what's up this is andrew for
childrensens.com so in this video i
would like to go with you through
yesterday and the day before yesterday's
price action on amc we had a lot of
volatility a lot of things happen and
can give us information for the next
moves so let's get into it
[Music]
all right so i'm gonna
start on the first time frame very
quickly we take a step back as usual and
we analyze what happened since gen 21 so
we had one strong move up correction
second strong move up correction we are
waiting for the next move up so we need
to analyze this correction and try to
find some levels uh that are going to
help us to know if it's finished or not
we're also going to use some other
indicators like mcd that i lost here
so we're also going to use some other
indicators like the momentum that going
to help us to know if a reversal is
likely to happen or not
so first
i did my last video here just after we
had the earnings announcements that were
better than expectations when i did my
video the aftermarket was around 35 and
i was telling you that we are set up to
go test the next resistance level that
is here represented by this uh upper
band so downward sloping trend line
connecting this high and this high all
right on the fourth step on the four
hours time frame and this is what
happened we opened i think at plus seven
or plus nine percent and then we tested
this level we slightly moved above but
we didn't close above which we need
which would be for me the major signal
that this correction is over
and then we had this nasty red candles
and closed the day down and then
yesterday was also a red day but let's
see what we had here so basically
resistance here rejected all right so
basically the bells were here very
strong you know there was a very hard
selling pressure here very strong
selling pressure and then we corrected i
had here a support at 31 that didn't
hold and you can see that here we had
another kind of you know what we can
call a bear trap right so that's why i
prefer now to make analysis on the
medium term for amc because the daily
moves are very very hard to predict it's
full of tricks so i'm gonna stay on this
kind of you know longer time frame
analysis and try to give you some
scenarios on the medium term
which is for me giving good results for
now so here we have this bear trap
definitely
why is it the bear trap because here as
you can see guys we have this this trend
line all right so first
tested
we got rejected here
then we gathered some strengths and we
managed to blow up this trend line so
here we have a short-term breakout that
was then retested here and that then
broke and right away we came back to it
all right so this is interesting to
analyze and basically we have here two
different so if i go on a daily
we now have two different candle
formations
that can indicate us what's going to
happen so up on the daily you can see
the trend trendline moved so i just need
to reconnect it to the high okay
because it's with or without the
aftermarket hours
but it's pretty much coming back to the
same
we have something like this and here so
this is a bearish engulfing all right
but bearish engulfing so when the candle
here is eating totally the previous
candle so you up and above you close
below this is a bearish signal but is
actually very effective when we are at
the top of uh of a bull trend here it
arrives kind of randomly so it's not
that powerful but it's still a very
nasty candle and the day after what do
we have guys we have this doji candle so
what does it mean it means that here a
lot of bulls have been trapped and here
a lot of bears have been have been
trapped so it's kind of even to me this
is offsetting each other effects
and
this is like the doji candle is a
reversal pattern and it's arriving at
the bottom of the trench so i would say
that this is uh slightly stronger than
the signal we had two days ago
now what is the situation so we had some
let me zoom in a little bit let's go to
hourly timeframe to see what happened
here
so like i was saying on my discord in
the amc recap this is a beautiful battle
between bulls and bears guys alright so
the bear camp is here in orange
and the bull camp so we have here
some brave soldiers that were at the 29
levels and that helped the price action
to go higher all right so here
but the real bull camp is to me lower
all right and we're going to have a
battle that is going to happen soon why
because this trendline is going lower
and the bear camp is gonna slide on it
so sooner or later we're gonna have this
battle so maybe we have here
some bulls as well all right
and they're strong yesterday they won
the end of the battle so maybe this
battle is going to be enough and you
know the price action will just pop up
here and start to develop uh into the
fifth wave or we're gonna slide lower
until so the end of this trend line is
the 2nd of september and sooner or later
in the kind of bearish scenario where we
go lower
sooner or later there's going to be a
battle and
you know what's my take here
the bulls are probably gonna win this
battle and it's gonna probably be the
victory that is gonna let us to the
fifth wave so let's see this is for me
too early to say for now the bear camp
is here maybe we're gonna test it today
again let's see to be honest i have no
clue about that
the only information i have and i'm
giving it to you
for a couple of days is this bullish
divergence that is positive for the
price action it's gonna impact the price
action roughly during the period during
between the lows so until the 2nd of
september so we have the bullish
divergence with us which is good
and that's it then we have those
scandals that are pretty much upsetting
each other's all right so the bearish
engulfing candle and the doji candle and
this is the situation for me so i cannot
really give more details here we need to
see more price action to find out uh
what is going to happen so for now my
scenario that is to me
holding is this wxy may be the y wave
that is complete this would make sense
in terms of fib ratios
we would be roughly to the one to one uh
relationship between y wave and w wave
which makes sense according to earlier
two theory so let's find out all right i
i don't have more information we need to
analyze what is going to happen but this
is also what i'm sharing with you guys
on my discord so it's too early i would
say to know what's going to happen next
week or in two weeks but what we already
know is that 24 is a strong support
level so this is the kind of strategy
that i'm sharing with you guys on my
discord this is to me uh the best option
trade
that can be done today according to and
using all the information that we have
from technical analysis so the
information we're having is that 24 is a
support level
okay
so let me first do like this okay so we
start from scratch
24 is a support level so we are not
scared about the price trading below
that level within roughly one month
because we know that even if we go there
maybe there's gonna be a battle but
probably the bulls are gonna flex the
muscles and we're gonna close above this
level in september so i would be a
seller of this right so
this is so you start to losing money you
can lose up to 2 400 us dollars a
hundred times less roughly if you finish
below 24 if you if you go to zero all
right this is the maximum loss but you
make this so that you make some premium
with this premium you can buy a 40
strike call why 40 because this is
roughly the resistance level it's maybe
not 38 so you can go lower so you buy
this one so now it costs only 200 us
dollars and once again as it will take
some time to go to the 130 level you can
so let's say 130 we can be a seller of
this because you know this is for me my
uh next strong resistance level so by
selling this we reduce the total premium
to 75 usd and we only cap here the
performance all right without it it's
like this and if you sell it you just
cap your performance so you basically
can
fully benefit from the upside movement
between 40 and 130 for a very limited
cost only 75 us dollars so this is the
type of strategy that i would be showing
you guys on my discord by the way for
those who want to join just click on the
link in the description of this video
and you can join one of our memberships
and you don't need to go for the
platinum one all right that i know is
expensive 150 a month is expensive but
trust me it's worth it we are gonna show
you guys their live trading so i don't
know if there are many youtubers doing
it but we are not only youtubers we are
traders and i'm taking once again a big
risk here because i want to show you
that everything that i'm talking about
all the techniques that you know i'm
using to make my analysis that give me
sometimes very good results that
sometimes are not helping me to predict
price at the price action are actually
efficient and this is my project this is
the reason why i created this place and
i'm very excited to start uh to do live
trading with you guys but once again if
you take the gold membership which is
still 25 percent off until the 15th of
august you can have access to any stock
analysis you can request to me or
gabriel a lot of stock analysis gabriel
is the trader that joined uh training
census two weeks ago he is amazing he's
using different techniques from mine so
it's gonna be very interesting to uh see
what is working better and what we can
do together
and if you just take the gold membership
you can already request every analysis
you want us to make and you can access
to or all our trade ideas that we will
follow and we will keep monitoring for
you guys so once again here let me go
back to this trade what i wanted to show
you so
let's go back to september i wanted to
show you that you can do the same
strategy so if you're on september uh it
costs you 75 us dollars and you need to
have
amc being between 40 and 130 to be in
the money on the 17th of september but
if you guys want to have more time and
go for the gen 22 maturity this makes
sense to me and you can see that here so
there is less advantage to be taken off
from the volatility because those
volatility are
closer but once again the vega is higher
on the longer term maturity so it has
more impact on the price and you can see
that here we actually have a negative
premium which means we receive money to
make this strategy so if you finish
between 24 and 40 in june 22
on the 21st you're gonna receive 140 us
dollars all right so this is cheaper
and it's giving you of course the same p
l profile the only difference is that if
the move happens in september this is
the payoff at maturity so you would need
to unwind your strategy and you will not
under unwind it for the full profits all
right so basically
it's giving you more time but it's going
to make less profits if the moves happen
early but once again it's giving you
more time so it's all depends on uh what
type of view you have on amc uh if you
hesitate you can still do one of each
right that makes sense too you can also
go to october maturity everything here
works depending on what you want to do
and the piano and the risk profile that
you want to have
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys